they had been buried alive
two weeks in the dark freezing
underground 600 meters down
this was the first miner returned to the
surface
his eyes blindfolded against the glare
of a sun not seen for a fortnight
one by one they were raised up and
delivered to safety
some were too weak to walk carried to
one of the 25 ambulances standing by
at the scene the first communication
from the trapped miners
received a week ago was a note saying
please don't stop
trying to reach us
and you can see just how thankful this
miner was that they did not
the rescuers checked the miners to see
if they had any injuries
and covered their eyes for protection
generally speaking
the rescue operation proceeded faster
than expected
after lifting all the trap miners
discovered we'll go on with the search
for other missing miners
on the 10th of january an explosion
blocked the main shaft at the hushan
gold mine in shandong province east
china
the mine entrance was blocked 350 meters
below the surface
by 70 tons of debris reaching down 100
meters
rescuers made contact with the miners by
drilling narrow shafts
sending telephones food and medicine
down
then they drilled a new wider shaft to
reach the miners trapped in the
midsection of the tunnel below
and bring them to the surface one miner
was confirmed dead from a head injury
others were in a bad state and they were
brought up first
the critical cases come before the
others it's the principle of mine
accident rescue
so the severe ones have been pulled up
first and the following are in better
physical and psychological condition
this is an ongoing rescue operation
though several miners are still
unaccounted for
they drilled more holes to try and reach
them and if they do find them
to send down food to try and keep them
alive and strong
china's mining industry has a terrible
safety record there have been multiple
deaths over the last two years alone
it is grimly unsurprising when a fatal
mining accident occurs
it is a miracle when like today people
survive
tom chester sky news beijing